dernier entraînement en forêt de
montargis avant un périple de 8000 km à
la force des mollets andré van den
broeck s'attaque à l'europe de l'est
quinze pays 80 kilomètres par jour 40 kg
de matériel bon à l'avant j'ai ma toile
de tente mon amant duvet le comment les
matelas tout pour dormir
et puis des vêtements également devant
en cas de pluie et de la pluie il en a
eu ces derniers jours lorsqu'il a testé
son équipement le long du fleuve royal
de châteauneuf sur loire à orléans
il faisait froid et il pleuvait ça
glissait donc d'un schéma ce n'était pas
l'idéal l'idéal mais ça fait partie d'
aventure
alors donc campé sous la flotte payer
sur la flotte wrp leur planter sous la
flotte
voilà ça m'a mis dans l'ambiance le
sportif dans l'âme entretient sa
condition physique
judo musculation marche nordique il a
participé à des dizaines de marathon et
de tous les sports le deux-roues
favorise les rencontres
c'est ce qui le motive je suis presque
en hypnose as fais serment vélo ce que
c'est en fait ça et je pense à ce que je
vais découvrir à ce que je vois ce que
j'entends les bruits le vent là les gens
ceux du bonheur andré débutera son
périple le 8 mai en allemagne là où le
danube prend sa source il longera le
deuxième fleuve d'europe pour rejoindre
la mer noire au retour il fêtera ses 64
ans il sera peut-être en turquie en
croatie ou en italie